sorry for our time it took for us to
organize ourselves we're a big big
family here big panel my name is Laurie
Goodstein I'm a national religion
correspondent at the New York Times and
I'm glad to welcome you here today this
is a panel on religion in the Quran it
is written that Muslims Jews and
Christians are people of the book and
that's about right
judging by the amount of publishing
going on in the field of religion as a
reporter on the religion meet I receive
at least five new books or galleys each
day and I've seen a dramatic change over
the years with of course 9/11 as the
dividing line before 9/11 I got a lot of
self-help titles books on angels on
charting your chakras what I call self
centered religion since then a lot of
religion books are more likely to
grapple with global weighty issues and
questions like can Islam Christianity
and Judaism coexist or will World War 3
start next year in Jerusalem are there
other Gospels that were left out of the
Bible and if so why do the Ten
Commandments have any bearing on how
people actually live their lives today
we're going to hear from the authors of
four titles that have risen to the top
of the stacks
they represent the breadth and diversity
of offerings in the religion field today
I'll introduce each book and its authors
before they speak to you we're going to
do this in three segments and they're
going to be very brief because I know
you're going to have a lot of questions
so we're going to start with the authors
of the faith Club
Suzanne Oliver Rania it'll Abbey and
Priscilla Warner they're collaborators
on the book the faith Club which is what
you would get if you took the TV show
the view and had Rosie O'Donnell
and Barbara Walters talk only about
religion after 9/11 these three
idealists set out to write a feel-good
children's book about the similarities
of their faiths Islam Judaism and
Christianity but they soon realized that
before they could affirm their
similarities they had to confront their
differences their arguments about the
crucifixion about God the Holocaust
Israel and Palestine they're all in the
book no-holds-barred suzanne oliver the
christian member of the group were up in
Kansas City Missouri where she made her
first communion at st. Elizabeth's
Catholic Church well she majored in
English literature in German at Texas
Christian University in Fort Worth she's
worked at financial world magazine at
Forbes as a senior editor and smart
money comm where she was managing editor
Rania it Lobby is a Muslim American
whose family was uprooted from Tiberias
a Palestinian town by the Sea of Galilee
during the creation of Israel she grew
up with a foot in the East in Dubai and
foot in the West in McLean Virginia she
graduated from Georgetown University's
School of Foreign Service and has a
master's degree from the London School
of Economics love and marriage brought
her to New York City where she lives
with her husband and two children
Priscilla Warner the faith club's Jewish
member were up in Rhode Island where she
received something of an interfaith
education by attending a Hebrew day
school and moving on to a Quaker High
School she graduated from the University
of Pennsylvania with a degree in fine
arts and spent 15 years and as an
advertising art director at various ad
agencies in Boston and New York inspired
by her two sons she began writing and
illustrating children's books she lives
with her family in Westchester County
New York so I introduced you to the
members of the faith club
thank you for being here um as you know
by now I am the Muslim mother I came to
the faith club out of a deep sense of
isolation and alienation from the public
dominant voice of assam after 9/11 as
the mother I was deeply concerned and
worried about what it would mean for my
american-born children to grow up both
American and Muslim I knew I needed them
to be proud with that challenge in mind
I sort of hit the books since start
reading and it doesn't take me long to
discover what I feel is the true inner
beauty of Islam the fact that Muslims
kneel down and prayer five times a day
and end their prayers the salutations of
peace to Abraham and this and his
descendants including Moses and Jesus
and the Prophet Muhammad the fact that
Muslims believe in the Gospels and the
Torah the fact that Muslims believe that
essentially Judaism Christianity Islam
are but three forms of one religion at
the root the religion of Abraham with
that in mind I'm excited and inspired to
reach out to a Christian mother and a
Jewish mother to try and do something to
write a children's book that would serve
to highlight the commonalities of our
face tradition no sooner had we started
talking though that of course the the
Jewish and the Christian mother started
having their own conflict which I let
them talk about but I'll leave you with
this thought as they were hashing it
between the two of them I kept thinking
they kept talking about the salient
points in the judeo-christian tradition
and I kept thinking why isn't it the
judo Christian Muslim tradition so when
they finally get to me and then dialogue
the dialogue centers on two stereotypes
the first one is of course the idea that
Priscilla came home soon from a cocktail
party and she said you know you say your
God is our God too but I don't know a
very erudite man said to me there Mecca
vs. Medina versus and so and so forth
the idea that within Islam within its
text at the text hold holds the root to
to conflict to a religion of the sword
spread by the sword I'm here to tell you
that nowhere in the Quran does it say
kill and you shall be rewarded and that
when really
is used to justify violence or as a
tactic of war it is no longer religion
but a human ideology has nothing to do
with God's values the second stereotype
is the idea of Islam being repressive
and anti women and I'm here also again
to counter that image to tell you that
1.6 billion Muslims in the world choose
to stay within the faith tradition of
Islam not because it's a it came to
suppress and discriminate against was
against women but rather the Prophet is
revered as someone who came to advocate
as a champion of women's rights um two
personal things had to happen I came to
the relay to the face club someone
describing herself a face but now
religion and through our dialogue I had
an affirmation I come out a more
confident and affirmed Muslim the two
big challenges for me was I needed my
face tradition is my religion to sustain
my belief in a universal God the good
news is it does there are many verses
within the Quran that confirms the idea
that had God willed he would have made
us all the same tribe creed religion but
it was by God's intended design that he
would have us of different religions
because he wanted us to know one another
and through our actions prove ourselves
the second issue is the idea that I
would have to dress a certain way wear a
veil perhaps or live a certain way
each a certain way to drink a certain
way in order to qualify as a Muslim I
was helped with that challenge through
essentially my finding an imam whose
wonderful and he was able to refine for
me the difference between religion and
face when he shared with me an anecdote
about the Prophet Muhammad when he was
asked what does it take to be a good
Muslim well the first thing is a belief
in God the second the prophecies the
third is to act as if God was with you
once you have fulfilled these three
requirements you have faith and then and
only then should you choose to you can
use your rituals of your face tradition
to service to your face so the face up
is basically a dialogue of the common
person it's a call for us to have this
dialogue we're here we're honored to be
amongst these wonderful scholars
theologians and people who are so
accomplished we are mothers who set out
to have a dialogue with our children in
mind and we found it so liberating in
our call is that
for you to go ahead and do the same and
for me personally as a fellow American
citizen to ask you to ask me the tough
questions please don't live under the
misconceptions and assumptions don't add
me as the other and for Muslims it's a
call to to read the Quran to make it as
part of your fabric of your life because
as Muslims I feel like we can celebrate
the universal God accessible to all we
have access to the Christian God the God
of passion and love the Jewish God the
mixes and actions and third the the
Muslim God God accessible to all I'm
very excited because I feel that in the
very near I know I'm going to fix me I
have I've been asked to summarize 60
minute presentations three I'm getting
down to my function line so this is it
I'm looking I I look at my daughter and
my son's not here but my daughter's here
and I'm very confident and secure that I
know that in the near future they'll be
able to speak of them and proudly speak
of the great American judo Christian
Muslim tradition I'm a Jewish mother I
came to this my crisis of faith was
purely about fear after September 11th I
was basically paralyzed terrified of
terrorism I Rana CLE had gone to a
Hebrew day school I was very well
grounded in my religion but I say I had
religion but no faith I answered a phone
call from Suzanne Oliver it seemed the
whole world was screaming about religion
and I thought well if I meet these two
women and I sit down and we talk calmly
about religion maybe something will come
of it little did I know we would not be
talking so calmly and quietly people say
we took off the gloves people say we
said things nobody says to each other we
built up a level of trust over a number
of years and I do think that it's a
conversation that many many people can
replicate but the most important thing
that I learned was the first tenant of
the faith club was honesty that everyone
wants to be validated for who they are a
very important lesson for me I came into
it with some stereotypes when I walked
into Ronnie's apartment I'd never met a
Muslim woman before I'd certainly never
met a Palestinian
before and later I wrote that I expected
I was shocked that Ronnie would sit down
and talk to me face to face so honestly
welcome he so graciously into her home I
grew up you know with this notion that
Jews were going to be pushed into the
ocean and instead she fed me fed me
beautifully and fed me body mind soul
all across the board I had some
stereotypes about Christians oddly
enough even though I went to a Quaker
school and had as I say some of my best
friends were Christians but I met a
woman a lot of the I think strengths of
this book is that we were all strangers
to each other Ronnie and Susana met at a
bus stop Susanne made a phone call and
got hooked up with me so I met a woman
who went to all Catholic schools grew up
in the Midwest Texas Christian
University who loved Jesus and spoke
about Jesus very openly and Jesus was
kind of a stranger to me I talked a lot
in the book about how Jesus is a
stranger to the Jews and when we got
into our discussion about the
crucifixion you have to read the book
because I've only got three minutes and
that's a good way to plug the book but
we got into very animated discussion
about Jesus and after Suzanne over the
course of many many months read to me
from the Sermon on the Mount and some of
my very favorite quotes quotes in the
book come from Jesus I'm proud to say
that I'm now in a first-name basis with
Jesus I talk about Jesus to my children
and I write in the chapter after you can
imagine the conversations we had after
the conversations that divided us we had
amazing conversations about what United
us as Rania says we all begin the same
way and we will all end the same way we
have all lost loved ones we've all
suffered pain one of the important
things I learned in the book my
conversations with Ronnie and Suzanne
was not to quantify suffering not to
compare my suffering to anyone elses it
doesn't really serve to move people
forward everyone has pain everyone
suffers but after the painful chapters
came my favorite chapters and I in the
end of the book started off as a person
without a definition of God by the end
of the book after flying over the Great
Lakes and looking down below me and
recognizing my humility which is Suzanne
Rania pointed out to me Islam means to
submit and that means to acknowledge
your humility in the universe
I shrunk myself down and paradoxically I
found enormous power in that and my
definition of God is the one now that
begins my book and smart and boomers
definition when two people relate to
each other authentically and humanely
God is electricity that surges between
them and I say that when we were
together sparks fly and the current is
very strong I might tell you a little
more about what some of those sparks
were um I am obviously the Christian I
came to the faith club project after
9/11 when like many New Yorkers and many
Americans I was interested in learning
more about the Middle East and Islam in
order to assess how safe my family and I
were in New York and what was going on
so I met Rania at the school bus stop
our daughter's started kindergarten
together that year and when she started
telling me the story she had come across
about the connections among Judaism
Islam and Christianity and told me her
idea of writing a children's book I
jumped at the opportunity to spread a
message of peace among three religions
whose differences were really fueling
violence and misunderstanding and hatred
I'm in fact she had already invited
another Christian and I grabbed the
phone and told her to cancel that other
Christian right away because I wanted to
join this project guess if I was going
to summarize my faith club journey very
quickly I would talk about it as one of
being from a certain amount of certainty
to doubt as I started the faith Club I
was very interested in learning more
about Islam and Judaism
I thought of Islam is a violent religion
controlled by men and filled with
mistreated women yet he was Rania who
wasn't covered who didn't seem to be
mistreated by her husband whom I met and
who drank a glass of wine and on
occasion I wanted to know how she
reconciled what her modern life with
what I thought of as the religion of
Islam and my knowledge of Judaism that
we shared the Old Testament was not that
much more substantial I thought of it as
an ancient and exclusive religion and
one that didn't benefit from Jesus's
message of love and life everlasting so
while I was interested in learning more
it was in a more of an academic sort of
way I didn't think that what I learned
was going to sway any inner conviction
or suspicion that I had
Christianity was the superior religion
of these three but then as soon as we
started talking everything that I
thought came into question and I started
a question language that I'd been using
for 40 years now you know how old I am
and not really not really thinking about
what that language meant too early on as
Rania is talking about her temple in
church Envy because she doesn't have a
mosque in New York where she feels very
comfortable I brought her to my
Episcopal Church and thought maybe it
could be a sort of a spiritual foster
home for her a place where she could
join in our charitable projects and we
had all celebrated this one-god that we
believed in so her family came with us
to Easter service and the music and the
flowers is all wonderful and then all of
a sudden we started talking about Lamb
of God and body and blood and the
sacrificial lamb and I started feeling
really self-conscious and wondered what
is this all mean that I've been saying
all the time and realizing that this was
actually something that separated us so
then there were other things that were
coming to the forefront right away as
Ronnie started talking about Muhammad's
mission on earth I felt Jesus's position
threatened by a follow-up prophet that
well hadn't God played his trump card
with Jesus why would he need to send
somebody else and as I was talking about
the crucifixion with um Priscilla and
she heard words differently than I had
meant for them to be heard and thought
that I was accusing Jews of being Christ
killers um she asked me at one point as
I was writing about Pentecost if I could
just leave the crucifixion out of the
story
so it shows you how far we've come
laughs about things like that now I
suppose as we talked about Priscilla was
talking to me about reform judaism zai
dia of a god existing without an
afterlife that really made me question
my own idea of God because God an
afterlife had always come hand-in-hand
as we came to talk about Jesus as a
symbol of love and suffering and I
started questioning whether he was
divined and I have to believe he was
divine as he was a Christian as I
started reading books like misquoting
Jesus I am started all these questions
came forward I was very lucky to have
access to a fantastic priest at my
parish who reassured me right away with
the words the opposite of faith is not
doubt its certainty and from that point
on I was really able to embrace my doubt
it kept me humble it allowed me to open
my mind I was able to see how Priscilla
and Rania both found elements in their
own tradition that fed their
spirituality that brought them closer to
God and I quickly will sum it up then I
brought him Priscilla and Rania with me
to st. James my church and we were
talking to the teenagers about our own
journeys as we were having our
conversations together and I think I'm
one of them asked us well in order to
believe in your own religion don't you
have to believe that the other two are
wrong and I think this was the Nugget of
what I was wrestling with through a lot
of the faith Club and I told them that
no I didn't think so that I didn't think
God differentiated between a good Muslim
we could do a good Christian a good
atheist and that if God didn't
differentiate then why should I and I
was able to find um certainly lots of
quotes within the Bible that I felt
supported that and as we have gotten
emails critical of the sort of
universalistic view that I've come to
even though the scripture that they put
forward I am the way the truth and the
life the only way to God is through me
is one that I see is being so open
because to me that says the only way is
by following Jesus message of love and
compassion for your fellow man and that
I know is common to all three of our
religions
thank you and thank you for keeping it
tight we I want to I want to give you
enough time to get to know these writers
but also to have a little bit of time at
the end to ask questions so our next our
next speakers are both going to speak on
a similar topic earlier this year the
National Geographic Society upset a
whole lot of people with the
announcement of a new archaeological
discovery the Gospel of Judas it turned
the Bible's version of Judas on its head
and among the experts whom the National
Geographic Society called on to help
interpret the text for the public were
these two writers I'll start with Bart
Ehrman who's at the end there he is the
author of the lost gospel he is a
distinguished professor at the
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill he chairs the Department of
Religious Studies there and his
specialty is the New Testament and the
history of early Christianity
now bark has his own interesting
personal history of Christianity I'd say
in his youth he was a conservative
evangelical and he attended Wheaton
College in Illinois
later at Princeton seminary he began to
question whether the Bible is the
literal inerrant Word of God his own
search for answers is reflected in his
scholarly books he's written and edited
19 books and among his most recent are
lost scriptures books that did not make
it into the New Testament and misquoting
Jesus the story behind who changed the
Bible and why I'll also introduce
Herbert Krasny he's the author of also
the lost gospel the quest for the gospel
of judas iscariot
he's a writer and documentary filmmaker
he specializes in investigative and
historical projects and his work for the
BBC PBS The History Channel and the
Canadian Broadcasting Corporation he's a
graduate of Harvard he reported for the
Alba new times Union newspaper and then
served in the US Army and then he moved
into television working for Sea
SABC and the predecessor of PBS national
educational television and how many
people remember that in 1968 he went to
Israel to head the documentary
Department of Israel television and in
1970 he formed his own documentary
company he's produced pieces on
Jerusalem World War two Russia and
Iran's nuclear ambitions in addition to
the lost gospel Crosby has written
several other books including beyond
welfare poverty in the super city and
deadly business legal deals and outlaw
weapons so I give you Bart Ehrman and
herb Grozny thank you in some sense
Christianity has always been in a state
of crisis because Christianity from the
very foundations of the faith has
insisted that Christ in some sense is
the way of salvation and yet Christians
haven't been able to agree on what that
way entails the Gospel of Judas that's
just been discovered and published just
six years ago six months ago now by
National Geographic is a good
illustration of how diverse early
Christianity was a Christianity today
continues to be extremely diverse if you
compare what a Greek Orthodox priest
thinks with what an Appalachian snake
handler thanks or an Episcopalian with a
Mormon or Jehovah's Witness with a
seventh-day adventists you have an
enormous range of beliefs and practices
among Christians today in in the ancient
world the beliefs and practices were
even more diverse my my expertise in
Christianity is in the 1st 2nd and 3rd
centuries in the 2nd and 3rd centuries
there were Christians who obviously
believed that there was one God there
are other Christians who believe that
there were two gods and some said there
were twelve gods we know of some
christians who said there were 36 gods
we have one Christian group that said
there were 365 gods which is very
convenient because then you could have a
god a day you are God for today
Christians believe some Christians
believe Jesus was both human and divine
some said he was human but not
some said he was divine but not human
Christian some Christian said God
created this world other said God never
had anything to do with this world
different Christians had different
points of view and they all claim that
their points of view represented the
views of Jesus himself
as as found in the writings of his
apostles all of these various groups had
books that claim to be written by
apostles that represented each of these
mutually exclusive points of view the
Gospel of Judas is one of these books
that now has been discovered that had
that illustrates quite well the
diversity of early Christianity the
Gospel of Judas is a product of early
Christian Gnosticism Gnosticism is a is
a term that scholars use for a range of
religions that understood that the way
of salvation is not by faith in Christ's
death and resurrection but by the secret
knowledge that Jesus conveyed Gnostics
understood that they were alienated from
this world because they didn't really
belong here this material world wasn't
created by the one true God this
material world is a cosmic mistake
created by lower divinities and the key
to salvation is to escape the material
trappings of this world the Gnostics
were people who felt completely
alienated in this existence they felt
like they don't really belong here this
world doesn't make sense to them I felt
this way since the last election the
world the world just makes sense to
other people well they belong here but
some of us don't well how do we get out
of here well we need to get the
knowledge necessary for salvation and
escape this world the gospel of judas
conveys this secret knowledge it's a
complicated book in some ways because
the knowledge that it gives the
revelation that it conveys is secretive
and mystical and hard to understand but
those who are in the inside the Gnostics
are the ones who can understand what
this truth is this this gospel was
condemned as a heresy in the second
century and was eliminated from
consideration from
Kanon of the New Testament luckily
though a copy of it was made in in Egypt
in the early 4th century or the late 3rd
century it got buried in a tomb and
luckily it turned up in 1978 the story
of how it was discovered and and how it
was handled by antiquities dealers until
finally we got a translation of it six
months ago is summarized for me in my
book on Judas but really the the entire
story is told at great length in her
progeny book on the lost gospel but
working with Bart was a pleasure because
in addition to anything else to wrote
the introduction to my book and I and
and it was a great great scholar of
early Christianity we really didn't know
much about the 2nd or 3rd century almost
everything that we know about the 2nd
and 3rd century which is the formative
periods when the church developed come
from the people who were representing
the church particularly Eusebius who
lived in Caesarea in what is modern-day
Israel the one of the things that has
fascinated me in terms of the early
history of the Gospel of Judas --is and
and impressed me was the closeness in
the 1st 2nd and 3rd centuries of Judaism
and Christianity and how the Gentile
peoples in essence adopting the Old
Testament were really adopting a history
which was foreign to them and which had
to be sold to them in many ways and a
lot of this was represented and brought
to fruition in the city of Alexandria
which 3 centuries before in the 3rd
century when it was founded by Alexander
the Great actually gave a charter to the
Jews saying you will be treated equal to
the Macedonians and it's a little known
history but actually Alexander is a
revered figure in Jewish history and
Gnosticism in many ways
there were too severe repressions of
Jews in Alexandria and Gnosticism is
believed partly to have developed out of
that and a lot of what you see in the
Gospel of Judas is a reaction a
criticism of the weather it was the fall
of the temple there there is a reaction
against the god of the Old Testament in
other words there was good news for the
Jews and the Gospel of Judas and freeing
up who the Jews were and the
responsibility for the crucifixion of
Christ but also it was a severe
rejection of the God of the Old
Testament and in fact the Gospel of
Judas is a highly polytheistic document
nonetheless as we come into the present
day we've had extremely interesting
reaction the Vatican people there's been
some journalists who have written that
the Vatican has been extremely critical
of us of Neoga Gospel of Judas in fact
the Vatican has not commented in any
official way and in over the last
fifteen centuries or so on what is
believed to be apocryphal literature but
I found myself on a number of television
programs not arguing with Catholic
priests but finding the key that certain
Catholic priests were were
reestablishing the early Christian wars
that Bart right so Abele about and
fighting against the Gnosticism which
they thought that they had defeated as a
dissident movement within Christianity
between the 2nd and 5th centuries then
the negative reaction the we've had
extremely a great interest in the entire
project among all the Catholic and
Orthodox countries meaning Russian
Orthodox and Greek Orthodox we have had
certain letter-writing campaigns by
certain evangelicals against the Gospel
of Judas as if we were responsible
somehow for this historical document
which came
of the desert what did what I think I've
brought away from it as the the the
sense of reverence that many people have
the need the need for a defining deity
and the closeness nonetheless with all
with all these conflicts nonetheless the
closeness among men of wanting to find
answers to their condition Thank You
Herr Chris Hedges is the author of
losing Moses on the freeway the book is
an indictment of how far Americans have
fallen from following the Ten
Commandments the books 10 chapters
reconsider the commandments through
Chris's reflections and vignettes of
people's lives very inventive vignettes
Chris's best-selling first book is war
as a force that gives us meaning it was
drawn from his experiences reporting on
wars in Central America in Africa and
Yugoslavia it was a finalist for the
National Book Critics Circle Award he's
also written what every person should
know about war Chris grew up the son of
a circuit writing minister in a small
town in upstate New York he and his
father talked Bible and morality every
Sunday while driving the churches where
his father was to preach he graduated
from Colgate University and then Harvard
Divinity School but he eventually
decided not to father follow his father
into ministry instead he pursued a
higher calling journalism
he worked for the Dallas Morning News
the Christian Science Monitor and
National Public Radio he joined the New
York Times in 1990 and was a member of
the team that won the 2002 Pulitzer
Prize for explanatory reporting for
coverage of global terrorism
he lives in Princeton New Jersey and has
a new book coming out in January
not at all controversial the title is
American fascism the rise of the
Christian Right Chris Hedges thanks I
just wanted to comment briefly I mean as
somebody who did grow up in the church
and then spent almost 20 years abroad
seven of those years in the Middle East
in Israel and the Muslim world eight
Richard Neave were the theologian had a
great line that you know religion is a
good thing for good people and a bad
thing for bad people there are passages
for instance in the Gospel of John that
are verily anti-semitic in the letters
of Paul you know denouncing
homosexuality you know there are moments
in the Hebrew Bible when God can be a
bigoted cruel tyrant that seems to bless
acts of genocide if one looks for
instance when Moses leaves Egypt and I
think that and of course the book of
Revelation or the book of Daniel which
are used extensively by the religious
right in our own country to justify and
yearn I think many ways feed a yearning
for apocalyptic violence and these
passages have to be dealt with because
they are within the Canon the Quran also
has very virulent passage not in the
early part but in the later part against
Jews and how do we deal with these I
think in some ways we have to accept
that those darker elements and those
people that perhaps a twitcher neighbor
would define as bad people can find
scriptural sanctification for their
hatred and bigotry and I think sometimes
we who reach out and embrace a more
whole or humanistic approach can ignore
those passages in the Bible just as
assiduously as I think the Christian
Rite will ignore a Sermon on the Mount
how do we cope with that how do we deal
with that I think we're entering an age
where the there are powerful forces
fundamentalist forces not both the
Jewish Islamic and Christian and of
course even Hindu that get scriptural
sanctification for blood lust violence
there has to begin or I think a more
concerted response on those of us who
believe in in the religious tradition
but I think embrace the values of the
Enlightenment and a kind of humanism to
denounce these passages within our own
scripture to denounce the book of
Revelation for instance I I think too
often we skirt that issue by pretending
that it's not there
and I think we're reaching a point even
with in American society where we have
to confront and the fact that you know
even in a Unitarian Universalist Church
pew in Boston there are within the Canon
of passages that that fuel movements
that I think are not only anti religious
but anti human thank you our panelists
out of respect for you really and
respect for each other have really been
very disciplined in their presentations
and that's to give you time to ask
questions so I open it up to questions
from the audience yes about the degree
of confidence and
what causes violence of course we know
this cliche that is both way perversion
of religion but I'm afraid that it's far
from peanuts
you know what sort of percent 10%
percent line person they understand what
they actually use what we go on the
spoils okay should I repeat the question
yes okay okay he is asking I'm not sure
which panelist you're asking maybe you
throw it open to the whole panel okay if
we really understand what are the causes
of religious violence well let me just
begin as somebody who'd covered
so-called religious wars in the Middle
East or Nuka Slavia which I think
fundamentally are not religious wars
there they are Wars born out of
collapsed societies and despair and I
really agree with Freud that people will
find ideological structures whether
they're religious oh you know I think
one could look generically a communism
or fascism as in generic terms a kind of
religion I think they share in common
many elements including that urinal
yearning for apocalyptic violence that
belief that violence can cleanse the
world purge the world make the world a
better place
and then of course in this weird kind of
spiritual Darwinism all the believers
will be lifted up their clothes left
behind with the rest of us who will rot
and burn and and so I think that that
that and I think Freud wrote about this
very well I think that what we're
dealing with this is those dark currents
that what Freud would call the love of
Thanatos or the death instinct which is
really what these so-called religious
systems are about it's about a yearning
for death I think it's something within
human nature and I think it's wrong if
there wasn't you know canonical passages
in you know the book of Revelation or
the Book of Daniel to justify it they
would find something else I I think it's
false to blame religion anybody else
want to respond to that that's a very
good request for something
rania I think very well but again I
don't believe the sources religion and I
feel that I should probably say
something because Islam suffers from
that it's a stereotype that somehow
within its texts it's some more prone to
this type of violent reaction I think
that yes we are seeing a manifestation
of this who are the M but it's a
minority and I think it's more a problem
of the condition of the state channels
of opposition we have it Islam is a
religion in countries for the most part
that we do not have opposition confirmed
pathways and and and and education and
civic society and and I think that's
really where the root of the problem is
rather than looking at it I mean few
people would think that one should just
look at the Bible to really understand
the Inquisition or the Crusades and
sometimes in our readings here of how do
we understand this violent reaction we
tend to so be so tunnel visioned and
just to look at the Quran which I don't
think is is the one problem you'll see
that after all pushed West 1840s 1850s
under Pope's of the days
gave us the justification to do whatever
we wanted the interest stuff do
essentially victimized Native Americans
especially
we used as justification for opening up
volunteer accent oh wait
comments okay that's before a comment on
his comment which is isn't the United
States guilty of something similar with
using manifest destiny okay good anybody
want to respond to it yes all right okay
it's very easy to to kill another or two
to justify violence eradication of
people so and so forth when you make
them other you demonize the whole entire
people culture population that's where
what we have to watch for
the racial terms of late
I ran this hook
and it makes the same thing
enslave the religion as
that's what children
it was the children
he's asking about the separation of
church and state he's saying in the
Bible there is a passage that can be
understood as the foundation for the
separation of church and state and is
there anything in Islam which which does
that and he's asking that of Rania very
much believe in separation of church and
state I think that there's nothing
inherently within Islam that would
require otherwise Indonesia is the
biggest Muslim state and it is a secular
state what else can I say I do not
believe that you know this could it most
um the studies that I've got a student
um was very much under the impression
that somehow Islam was an exception it
was different but you know I from a
common person point of view or I sort of
feel like well Judaism has a lot to say
about how you carry your personal life
to how you consummate a marriage or you
maintain a kitchen the Catholic Church
has a lot to say about birth control so
I feel that these are all issues that
can pretty much be handled nothing
that's particularly it's Muslim that
would otherwise rip RIF prevent us from
separating church and state Chris do you
want
well there's the concept of Sharia in
Islam and it is a belief at least among
certain Muslims or the small radical
wing if you want to call it small that
does believe in a unify and imposition
of Islamic law over entire societies and
they are fighting for that and you know
I'm not I'm not even being judgemental
but it's just about absolute fact that
that that is one of the tenants of
certain elements within Islam well you
know John Calvin believed the same thing
I mean you can find it in you know
Christianity as well so Islam's hardly
exclusive upon yeah in fact crit I mean
Christianity historically is not
advocated the separation of church and
state the I mean as soon as the Roman
Emperor converted to Christianity nobody
wanted there to be a separation of
church and state so it's really it's a
post enlightenment phenomenon that this
whole idea that has nothing to do really
with with we having any religious
impetus okay one last question yes a lot
of you always think that they're really
peace and they don't want like violence
there's so much racism I'm like no
everyone's always fighting about
religion okay alright the question a
good way to wrap up our panel he said so
many religions preach about peace so why
is there so much racism and why is there
so much violence within religion or
within I think in the world this is
where you're asking why is the world the
way it is please please me I'll need to
start people need to start talking when
you talk about peace and religion Ron
yet Suzanne and Rania came with me to a
Yom Kippur service at my synagogue Yom
Kippur is the holiest day of the year
for Jews Day of Atonement and when we
fast and we pray for another year of
life and to be forgiven for our sins and
when we sat shoulder